[Music]
you
sailes class which is building and
managing professional sales
organizations was started eight years
ago nine years ago by jim latin who many
of you probably remember from the GSB
and Mark Lesley another person that's
been around the campus for quite some
time
they started teaching that class like I
said I think is eight or nine years ago
one section 35 students we now teach
four sections they're more or less
filled up at sixty to sixty-five
so there's demand for this content and
it kind of makes sense right if you
think about as CEOs entrepreneurs you
look at your P&L and there's that big
line item for for sales and then you
think back of a think back to your
curriculum at the GSB and you know you
had four finance classes and six
marketing classes and maybe if you were
lucky for the six of you that took the
sales class you got to address that one
function that seems to account in many
businesses for 30 40 50 percent of your
of your expenses so what we try to do in
the Stanford class is take some of the
mystery out of it and turn it from a
black box into something that's a little
bit more structured a little more
science behind it and and try to take
some of the the mythology or surround
sales out of it so in five minutes or
ten maybe I'm gonna try to paint a
picture of how to think about building a
go to market model building a sales org
and I've tried to organize these topics
from most strategic to increasingly
tactical or operational and I sit on a
handful of private boards and I help
with Excel partners from on the venture
side and point number one I think is the
biggest challenge I think companies
really face with as it relates to sales
orgs and sales productivity which is
they look at the sales organizations
lack of productivity and they don't
really recognize that the real challenge
they have is they haven't really
chief product market fit and you see
this all the time in private venture
backed companies where companies start
to expand their sales organization
before they have real product market fit
so I would say this is the number one
source of low sales productivity and
like I said the common error is scaling
sales before you truly have product
market fit one I'll just throw out there
one proxy that I like to look at for
private stage companies in terms of just
getting a gut feel for whether they've
achieved product market fit is if the
majority of their sales reps have
achieved their quota for at least two
quarters right I see I see this all the
time as a company might have a handful
of sales people on average they're
making their quota right but what that
really means is one person knocked it
out of the park and everybody else is
falling short and that law of averages
doesn't work very well and so they so
companies interpret that as as
repeatability and product market fit and
they start pouring money into the sales
organization they burn a ton of cash
turn over a bunch of sales people and
that cycle begins therefore you need to
pill raise more money on and on so a
second important again the kind of more
strategic question is is clear
segmentation this is that whole kind of
rifle shot versus shotgun approach do
you have focus and who in who you're
targeting and I think from a sales go to
market perspective you should have a
very clear coverage model in other words
who sells what to whom as your company
gets larger and you might have inside
sales and field sales and channels
having clear a clear coverage model a
coverage map of who's who's selling what
the home is is super-important we spend
a bunch of time on that in the GSB class
and then you know the go to market model
this is not an ala carte menu I think
that who you sell to what you sell what
your value proposition largely
determines whether you're going to go
direct you go through OEMs whether
you're gonna go through resellers what
type of resellers or have some kind of
hybrid model right and again having some
understanding of what the pros and cons
of
of those fundamental go to market
structures mean is super important and
then the sales model economics given who
you're selling to what you're selling
what your value proposition is your
chosen go to market can you foresee some
years out actually the economics working
on right it there are many circumstances
and I see this often where the go to
market model required to sell whatever
product and service you're selling will
never make sense economically and and
typically this comes where the product
requires a lot of heavy lifting it's a
big-ticket evangelical sell to a lot of
to bigger companies multifunctional
multifunctional decision making and the
price points too low the sales cycles
too long again we're kind of back to
product market fit again kind of classic
problem so can you make any money doing
this or at least can you grow fast
enough cuz you don't actually have to
make money do you is that an
old-fashioned notion I put and make
money up there and I thought how do you
sound so old so those decisions in red
then drive these decisions in blue who
are you gonna hire
what's the hiring profile right what's
your what's your organization structure
you know if you're a SAS business today
everybody defaults to this organization
structure around SD ours and then sales
wraps and customer success people and
you have channel managers and you have
SDR managers and sales managers and
pretty soon you get twelve people taking
a bite of every deal you know back in
the good old days this is B to B not B
to C we would sell software to the end
customer they would pay us all upfront
if they wanted post sales hand-holding
we would charge for it imagine that
right sales reps found and killed their
own deals so no SD ours
economics looked fantastic now fast
forward to today got an SDR pound pound
on the phones or emails spam and all of
our prospects if they find something
that's lukewarm they passed it to a
sales rep they closed the deal sales rep
passes it over to a customer success
person do you want to tell people that
SDR czar house sales development reps
prospectors usually young hungry
inexperienced cheap so that's the model
d'Azur and sometimes it really works the
problem is it it's not a one size fits
all and so if you're in a SAS business
today people just kind of adopt this
model without thinking through first
principles and they find themselves
upside down and for obvious reasons so
while I'm a big big fan in certain
circumstances of all the things I just
talked about you have to be careful not
to just absorb what everybody else is
doing as your as your org structure and
your go-to-market model you need some
first principle thinking around these
things again it's starting to be a
little bit more tactical all of the rest
of it kind of falls apart if you don't
get some of this operational stuff down
so you have to make decisions around
territory definition right how do you
rebalance territories when you add new
reps this is a great problem to have
because it generally means you're
growing right but you know that there's
a couple ways you can do it you can do a
mirror in a meritocratic way where
everybody has equal opportunity in maybe
the best salesperson when or you know
kind of the way a lot of the older
school companies do it which is
whoever's in first and closes the deal
hangs on to it forever so the new reps
come in and you know they get Gilroy as
a territory and the old reps get San
Francisco and they wonder why the new
reps never succeed right so so there's
some cultural ramifications to these
decisions you have to make compensation
plan decisions we talked a ton about
this in the GSB class needs to be a
three by five if it's too complicated
fit on a three by five card you're
over-engineering it right
and and this is one of my favorite
topics because you know as analytical
MBAs everybody wants to create the
master comp plan that micromanages the
activities of this very complex and
expensive sales organization and in some
ways that's just a crutch for not
managing through a number of things that
should be managed through forecasting
one of my favorite topics
you guys love forecasting right so can
you forecast your business 90 days out
plus or minus low single digits who can
who can do that in here yeah
few people your business is Trant more
transactional in nature or a bigger
ticket clear your ticket and you can
predict so we should talk right because
it's the selling bigger ticket b2b
software and being able to forecast your
business plus or minus single-digit 90
days out is is very unusual it's also
requirements we want to go public right
and the percentage of companies that
actually go public again my background
is b2b for those of you that are the b2c
business I apologize but in the b2b
space if you look at the track record of
companies that go public and then how
many quarters they go before they miss
because they can't forecast their
business it's pretty high percentage
shockingly high percentage it's hard
it's hard but not impossible to do but
it's also forecasting is not a reporting
process if done correctly it's it's a
management right it's a way to manage
activities and results it's a way to
manage an organization it's not just a
reporting function and again we spend a
ton of time on that in the end the GSB
class performance management this is
another great topic this idea of of
performance plans improvement plan
performance improvement plans what's the
HR acronym of the day pit plans
performance improvement plans is that
what we do now right we we look at sales
organizations
you're not performing we put you on a
performance improvement plan I'm telling
you I never did that I never did that
because I think it's lazy management
right performance management is about
setting expectations early and and then
let me back up I would argue that the
right way to do performance management
is is to give everybody a plan on day
one but it's not a performance
improvement plan
it's a QuickStart plan that everybody
signs up to the the the individual
contributor the individual contributors
manager everybody agrees to what success
looks like over the next 90 days when
you track that over the next 90 days and
if it doesn't work out then it's time to
move someone out rather than this
retrospective look put someone on a plan
to cover your asses HR which i think is
kind of a disingenuous way to manage
people and then development right skills
training and development too many sales
organizations think training is a
one-week onboarding class and then you
know death by PowerPoint from product
marketing organization and you know once
a quarter when they come in and have a
few beers and watch these slideshows
that's not training that's not skills
development I was noticing that well
I'll come back to this one of my first
companies that I worked for to make your
way up the management chain you had to
take a side detour in many cases and
become a trainer right a sales trainer
and that basically meant and by the way
there was no compensation bump so if you
were a sales rep and you wanted to go to
that first level management job you're
making three four five hundred grand a
year you get to take a sales training
job pays about 150 and you're gonna go
live on a plane for a year and you're
going to basically take your best
practices and go on hundreds or
thousands of sales calls with the rest
of the sales organization trying to
income
Cape them with what made you successful
and if that all goes well you get a
management job right it's fantastic it
worked fantastically that's how
seriously that company took it whereas
other companies you know the sales
trainers tend to be the people that
didn't make it in sales or didn't make
it at marketing or didn't make it in biz
death which is kind of the graveyard for
salespeople right so how seriously to
you as an organization take development
of skills and training your salespeople
not only as a way to make their
productivity better but also as a
retention device right so there's a I
notice this the other day on LinkedIn
there's a company in the Bay Area called
MongoDB
does anybody know this company so that's
that sales organization is essentially
the the children and stepchildren of
this company that I just described and
the CEOs on LinkedIn talking about how
they're hiring and the headline is all
about how they're gonna they're going to
develop you as salespeople and sales
managers to be the best in the industry
that this is where you get your
essentially sales MBA I thought you know
it's so rare to see that and what a
fantastic differentiator for a company
trying to hire the best and the
brightest in in sales I thought that was
super smart but when I looked at the
lineage of the people they're all like I
said sons daughters cousins of of people
from this company that that I was
fortunate enough to work for in my early
career so that's kind of a big picture
down to more tactical execution oriented
topics so I'm gonna pull Lukas in here
I'm gonna ask him a real-world question
that I think came from someone in this
in in the community here and then he's
gonna pose a question to me and then
we're gonna open it up and try to solve
some real-world problems right so this
question from one of the attendees was
I've just taken over my company and we
have two salespeople who report to me
I'm the CEO I think we can have 10
salespeople in two years and grow a lot
more after that should I be looking for
a director of
sails or a VP or what right by the way
this is a super common question I get
from former students who are out
building and buying companies it's Lucas
it's a super common question I get from
new operators I mean the answer might be
a little controversial but I'm gonna say
neither and the reason for that is it
goes to a little bit of what Kurt was
saying before which is increasingly in
this form of entrepreneurship sales is
the highest and highest order task to
get good at to ensure success it used to
be that search funds were smaller LBOs
and I think what we've seen over time is
yes you still are using financial
engineering to generate returns on five
to ten percent top-line growth but the
most most successful outcomes for search
fund entrepreneurs or where they've
bought into situations where they can
learn to how to do their version of
sales well and get to fifteen twenty
twenty five percent growth organically
repeatably over time and then you know
you get the boost of the leverage but
your return is generated mainly by how
good you get it
selling what you sell and as a search
point entrepreneur you're never gonna
learn that upfront if you hire someone
else immediately it's up to you to get
in there and ask yourself how do I sell
and to whom should I be selling and that
takes longer than two years and arguably
some of us are still learning how to do
that but and it evolved as you evolve as
a business so I think the onus is on you
is the opera's the entrepreneur to to
take over that function to work with
those two people to say is am i in a
service that's bought or sold and if
it's bought that means one thing and if
it's sold that means another in terms of
how you organize what should the goat I
understand what the go-to market is now
clearly that got you a little bit of
success but it's definitely not what's
gonna get you to where you want to be so
what should that go-to-market be and
then start thinking about who that
leader is and then you ask yourself do I
want a director or a VP and I think that
decision is more driven based on where
you think your company is in its
evolution one of my main
takeaways from the sales class at the
business school I think I was in maybe
the first or the second year it was
taught was in hiring a VP of Sales you
are hiring that person sales model they
will come in and sell how they know how
to sell and so I think that it that
should inform you as an entrepreneur
that you need to understand what you
think the answer to how you should sell
is before you're ready to hire that
person so in my specific case honoring
it literally on-ramp had two salespeople
there as far as I could tell they were
basically just picking up the phone
which was a is it not I don't mean
picking up and I'm sorry it's more
passive they were answering the phone
when it rang which generally means
you're in a good industry and and over
time we've had to learn this we didn't
hire a VP of Sales until we were four
years in it didn't hire a director
before it's the best time I've spent in
the business in terms of really being
able to create scale to grow this thing
so my question for you is another
question that was asked by the group
which is I think a little bit further
along the evolution so I and the
situation is such I've I have a couple
reps I think I know I think I know how
we sell I think we're along the path
we're seeing progress how do I build a
culture of a high-performing sales team
yeah so a high performance sales team if
I were to quantify it means means what
highly productive probably so there's no
silver bullet right I think if you want
a high performance sales team you have
to you basically have to nail all of
these you can't if you don't have great
product market fit I'll start at the top
it doesn't matter who you hire right
I've seen great organizations selling
low value proposition products and the
result is low productivity non high
performance
sales organizations if you were to
transplant that sales organization into
a company that had better product market
fed a stronger value proposition they
they might be fantastically productive
so that's where it that's where it
starts I was fortunate along the way to
work for VMware I was the VP of Sales
there for a while and you know I guess
we're being recorded so I'll watch what
I say but maybe the most dysfunctional
management team I've ever been a part of
and we crushed it right
perhaps because product market fit was
so incredibly high alright and I've been
part of organizations that were
incredibly functional where the value
proposition was not so strong and it was
like pushing a rock up a hill every
single day you've been there right you
know what the difference is you know
what it feels like when there's pull
from the market and what's your you can
see it in the eyes of the prospects and
the buyers right they get excited about
what you're selling the value
proposition is just resonates so
strongly that you're rolling rock down
the hill I was on the board of Atlassian
great example of a company that
everybody loves their products and they
have such a great competitive
differentiation that there's a ton of
pall and that makes everybody's life
easier and I imagine we've all kind of
been in those scenarios where everything
feels like a boulder being pushed uphill
and it's generally a function of the
first one although even if you have that
you have to nail the rest of this if you
really want to knock it out of the park
so it's long answer to a short question
so let's open it up let's let's try to
solve some real questions Lucas
you thought about hiring the director VP
for 3-4 years is that role purely
managerial role or is it a player-coach
and do you think that that role has to
be a the other I think it's it's
situation specific we hired a pure
manager but there's no in sales there's
no such thing as a peer manager as CEO
the business I'm so I'm like actively
selling all of our biggest deals so it's
not I don't I don't carry a bag foot
while I carry the bag of the P&L but I
don't carry a it's not going to impact a
quota that I have and so the person we
hired his goal was to to systematize and
and and really drive that next phase of
growth with both systems and processes
and with the recruitment of good people
but he was actively in the room on all
the biggest deals he or she he or she is
quote his quota is a rollup of all the
individual quotas minus 10% into
perpetuity and his variable comp is his
total variable comp is a very high
component of his total cop
a pretty tactical question which is I
think an age-old or perennial problem
with a Salesforce on comparing where the
Commission continues as long as the
customers keeps buying the dilemma
really is in our experience people get
to a comfort level and of the existing
book of business and how do you manage
that balance of focus - hey we want new
business you know this is all great but
we need your time focused on new
business and the simple answer of course
is compensation but even when we've kind
of skewed comp dramatically commission
rates towards new business there's still
a kind of phenomenon where folks get a
little fat and happy and it's really
hard to motivate them to put the time
into prospecting and new business I
think he started down the path to answer
your own question right so it's about
it's about focus so what would be the
next step beyond increasing the
commission rates for new versus existing
business what's the logical next step
well I guess non-financial performance
metrics to try and drive there how about
just operating the organization and
having I thought of people that just
does your business trigger the repeat
revenue not recurring correct
it's repeat although some of its
reasonably contractual movies and we
tried that but then you walked straight
into another dilemma which is hey fred
is the one that sold me Fred in fact was
a large part of the reason that I chose
to do business with you
what if regular so let me ask you your
product you're saying your relationship
with a customer is so sensitive that if
you pull your sales rep you risk the
business so in other words they're
really not buying the product or the
service the value proposition is such
that it's more about who sold it to them
partly because the role is partly
coordinating new projects and
and this some a degree of effectiveness
required to be have a comfort level that
the next project is going to go smooth
with the product or services boy out of
home advertising projects so so big
production to to get down the hole so
you have a few different levers here and
I don't think I'm telling you anything
you don't already know
you can change commission rates for
where you want people to focus you're
saying that doesn't necessarily work all
that well the next logical step is you
segment people between selling new
business so they wake up on a rainy
Monday and that's all they focus on
right and then folks that are
essentially managing the existing book
of business the third thing you want it
you can do if you want to keep people
both selling new and managing old is you
need to keep redistributing territory so
that the only way for them to reach
their goals is to do both so rather than
holding on to every deal they ever
closed infinitum right you just have to
keep rebalancing like like you would
your your investment portfolio at the
end of every quarter or at the end of
every year so those are kind of the
lovers you have the fourth one is
management which is you know I would
talk to my sales organization every
Monday morning and things that I thought
important were important weren't always
in the complan and and so you can manage
pretty aggressively to other measures as
well if you want so those are the levers
you have okay I put that into search fun
context for a little bit that's all true
I agree with all that the single that
most of you if you're within the first
three years of your operating experience
will be faced with this decision and it
will seem it seems hard and different
businesses are aligned differently but
the reality is if you're bought it most
of us are buying contractually recurring
revenue businesses and see this I would
just say it this way one of the biggest
drivers of success we had it on ramp was
separating the two creating that focus
and in getting our best people on the
highest priority
buckets within both of those if you give
a salesperson more than one thing to do
and he knows that the easier thing will
get him to his goal each time he will do
the easier thing and rarely is the
easier thing the thing will lead that
will lead to longer term growth for your
business you're trying to grow as fast
you can do you know to a certain extent
our product development was in the early
days this is a relative result of our
sales guys going out and selling things
that we couldn't exactly do that way at
the beginning which is a familiar
probably restrained for a lot of you
people for a lot of you for us it was
about figuring out what we are good at
and only focusing on that so when we
bought on-ramp we bought a portfolio for
different business models we were a
pure-play colocation player we were
managing a dedicated hosting player
calling ourselves a managed hosting
player we were a subscale ISP and we
were like an application development job
shop and over time we realized we've
shed totally shut those shut the revenue
down on the gulp tart shut the revenue
down on two of those and just focused on
pure-play colocation and developing
enterprise class private cloud business
and then the hybrid that comes with that
so for us it was much it was less about
sort of evidence that one was selling or
another and more about strategically
where we wanted to be and define
ourselves in the market is that that's
probably not very smart
it's about some of the questions you've
learned with selling higher dollar value
contracts under K Plus under our
overhang that J plus and M are our
annual AC annual contract you have many
of those yeah but this is you see here
here's you awesome
so narrow it down a little bit I mean
that's a broad question so let's say
$100,000 plus deal probably requires a
longer sales cycle so you probably had
to dedicate more resources on
prospecting and focusing on getting to
my decision-making I'm closing the deal
ahead of being able to collect the cash
for sure right so this is you know in
the venture business we've it was pretty
unfashionable for a while to do these
these big-ticket b2b companies and still
to some degree it's not as sexy as doing
the next Facebook or whatsapp or
whatever right for exactly this reason
which is as the ticket prices get bigger
but price is generally a proxy for other
complexity right so if you're selling si
P for example you're having to convince
multiple functions within the
organization to buy into this thing
right so the complex prices web proxy
for complexity it's often a proxy for
the how business critical or business
important the product or service is so
again scrutiny gets higher as price tag
goes up you know the approval cycles and
the internal ROI justifications get
harder so that's all true right
and so you invest all this money and in
expensive salespeople to go execute that
go to market model and you start getting
upside down on cash pretty pretty
quickly so that's I think one of the
reasons these these big-ticket b2b
companies kind of fell out of favor and
everybody wants a smoother more
transactional way you know land and
expand instead of top-down in order to
make the economics work the fact of the
matter is is is all all of those
building blocks on there have to be
addressed in the context of a big-ticket
sale so who you hire is going to be
different right how you forecast the
business is going to be different one of
the critical areas I think companies
make is they don't look at leading
indicators of the business and long sale
cycles so you know they wait nine months
the deal doesn't materialize and they've
burned all this cash and they don't know
why it didn't happen right so the
forecasting process has to move from
what are you going to close this week to
how are you going to move from the
qualification stage to the validation
stage and what are the entry and exit
criteria for each of those stages
and can we validate it and verify it and
make sure and get comfortable that we're
pouring this money into this this cash
into this go-to-market bucket we have to
get comfortable that something's going
to come out the other end and we can't
wait and end up with a goose egg
right so forecasting has to change like
I said people have to change how you
manage it has to change your capital
structure has to change you know you got
to raise more money there's there's a
bunch of things that go into that so
hard to narrow it down to one particular
lesson or not yeah Harrison let's say
your company let's say you're not in
Silicon Valley software that's like five
cops right nearby and you know the other
CEO is right so you're out there and you
haven't delegated to some Director of
Sales you're you're hiring fresh guys
and gals and you want to have better
than the average success lower than the
average turnover how do you figure out
who's ego succeed are you guys believers
in you know the personality testing kind
of model like how do you figure out
who's gonna work I'll give my opinion
it's a great question and then Lukas why
don't you want you pile in the I always
start from the perspective if I can
don't hire strangers all right so four
critical jobs the way you the way you
increase your batting average is you
hire people you absolutely know our
performers and and and so I think a lot
of entrepreneurs don't spend enough time
working their own network before they
default to hiring a recruiter and a
recruiter is lowest common denominator
in many cases for hiring any position
but salespeople in particular you know I
reference this company I started to work
for parametric back in the day we got to
half a billion in revenue before we ever
used a recruiter right and so we've now
arguably maybe a little a little later
than we needed to but everything was
exaggerated to make a point in that
company but the idea was we forced
management to exercise their network to
find people now we became a little bit
too homogeneous I think so there's
downsides to that but the lesson is is
that our hit rate in terms of hiring
people that made it and succeeded was
much higher because great salespeople
know great salespeople so that's one
place I would start
so relying on much much more network oh
yeah and you see ones that really does
that ever have it you told me that some
GSB grad doesn't have a network yeah I
struggle with that I just don't think
you might have to work harder but I
don't think there's anybody in this room
but it doesn't have enough are you fair
the GSP network is like I know a bunch
of people in hedgerow I listen well come
on you how do you know Lucas and I'm old
enough now you I'm assuming you made
some friends along the way right yeah
but I'm just mind you that it's a valid
concern I'm not saying it's the GSB
network specifically might be got it
but we collectively have a huge network
to mine right so that's where I would
start I can add my a couple of comments
I fully agree about the recruiters I
think it's and I fully agree our best
salespeople come from people that we
know are good and they say they're good
I fully agree with that but you're not
gonna have that upfront a first
heuristic for me is never higher sales
person that doesn't already have a job
and there's lots of them and they're
between jobs and whatever they tell you
about why they're between jobs it's
probably not true because as a CEO of a
business I am never letting my good
salespeople go I'm gonna do whatever it
takes to retain them so that's a good
heuristic the second thing I generally
say is it's a constant process of
testing and learning I would not run
towards process like I would not run
towards a personality test at the
beginning until you've done some failing
and you know everyone's gonna fail on
this but it took a while for us to for
me to understand my first crack at it
was i sat down and I said what are the
qualities I want in this person what are
the questions I can get to get to ask to
get there and then over time it evolves
and you sort of you see and then about
three years in we put in a process where
we were able to go we have it's like a
personality test but we were able to go
and have all of our Salesforce take it
first
and so we were able to see how they
scored and we we could say these were
the people we like and the people we
want to hire and then from an informed
perspective we can we can do that but I
wouldn't rush towards a process until
you have a better sense of what's going
to be successful or not so you know I
just practice you know when you can't
find people that you know or something
you know you know sometimes just feel
like you're just you know grabbing
almost at random based on good interview
skills but every one every one of us has
done a search done in here how
definitionally has high emotional e.q
because you've convinced smart wealthy
people to invest in you right and that's
worth something you can sit in a room
and tell that this person's a total
clown face most of the time you're not
going to get it right all the time and
that's fine and your board doesn't
expect that you get it right all the
time
you just got to get you just kind of get
like one or two to boost it and then you
can go from there so I would argue that
just maybe slightly contrarian because I
think this is an important topic i
discount the interview heavily right so
if I were looking at someone I didn't
know I would weigh track record yeah
eighty ninety percent and then the
interview an interview for me is an
opportunity for someone to talk
themselves out of a job right I'm
they're not good there's nothing they
can say or rarely they can say in the
interview that's going to overcome the
body of work so I'm really looking at
the body of work confirming it in the
interview allowing them to talk and how
do you look at what's how do you look at
the body work it's not just the rest
that's a longer discussion yeah it's not
just the resume it's a big piece of it
but yeah it's a it's it's there's a lot
of evidence there yeah so I've recently
allowed myself to believe that the right
consultant can accelerate a new CEOs
understanding of how this product market
fit
has to be
put together it's a very complicated
puzzle a mime am i deluding myself in
thinking that that a good outside
advisor can help can accelerate the CEOs
learning or is just like Lucas said you
got to spend two years figuring it out
on your own this is correct me if I'm
wrong right but in the search business
you're mostly buying companies that have
some product market fit right yeah so I
guess I don't really understand the
question you buy are you buying a
company that does not have product
market fit and you're searching for it
well I think what unless if you're doing
that that's that's what I think happens
often buying companies where the seller
was the chief sales rep and he through
sheer force of personality landed lots
of deals and is as he landed more deals
he had to manage the management job
encroached on his selling ability so he
hit a plateau so there really aren't any
training manuals there really are
writing scripts there aren't any decent
compensation plans but that to me the
sounds and again in the time we have are
hard to really get to the core of that
but if you tell me that someone has a
business where they have successfully
sold many many customers that tells me
there's some product market fit there
right even if the sales wrap is or if
the the former owner is a bit of a force
of nature
that only goes so far if so what you
would look at there is did the early
customers stick with the product or
service and if they did there's probably
good product market fit there or at
least there's some core of strong
product market fit what you're talking
about is how do you how do you capture
what that previous owner did what
motions did he go through to
successfully land new customers you have
to extract that out of his or her brain
and and replicate it
make sure the parking fair question yeah
just gotta follow up on that the common
pattern we see is that the guy that's
selling the business is kind of run out
of gas either because he's taking on
other management pools or he's just
colder right and so he's been maximizing
it profitability so we'll find the
business and the two fundamental risks
from an investor standpoint you're
taking a one management transition and
to it can you reject growth into the
business they're using these mechanisms
that you're talking about so yeah
there's a product market fit that the
company's not growing anything that's
acceptable to the investors to get a
good return so we have to figure out
this how do these young people who come
into this business you know begin to put
together professional sales force it
probably isn't in this company right and
so yeah there's a product market fit but
the question is is it too small you know
there's not too small
how does he expand may not be I mean
I'll defer to Lucas on this but in many
cases it's again this is this is so
subject to the specifics of the company
right but in many cases the product
market fit is there yeah it's right and
it's about changing the go to market
model changing the approach to marketing
there's no that number of changes you're
buying you're generally buying a company
that that has product market fit but
you're buying a company from an
entrepreneur who is not a professional
salesperson and and and and some of the
times that that growth that you're
talking about
it could be distraction from the person
or it could be that we've reached the
limit of his version of go to market and
you need to figure out what the new go
to market is gonna be him I think that's
the bigger question and so it's less
about it's more about understanding how
you sell and how you want to deploy reps
and how you want to compensate them and
how you want to create focus and then
and that and a big part of that too is
you know let's think about what the
value proposition is how you're going to
market otherwise we're just wasting time
what one way to think about this whether
it's a search fund or whether it's a
venture-backed company is I tend to get
excited about personally for making
investments in companies that are
successful despite them despite
themselves in other words I look at
their go to market model and it's pretty
bad it's pretty broken it's pretty
junior varsity but they're still doing
really well so what that tells me its
product market fit and is there and the
value proposition is strong and then you
can do something about this other motion
and really crank up the value of the
company that's been a reoccurring theme
for me personally in terms of is there
but one of the parameters of a source
fund is like a lifestyle right the guy's
not running it in exactly the same steam
so that lifestyle for however long and
you don't know exactly for how long
you're six months or two years would
allow the product market fit to be not
perfectly aligned as you want it and the
question that Jim was asked which I hope
I understood it right was if you were to
bring an outside consultant would it
dilute your role as a CEO and and I
don't know if that was a question
exactly but but did you my question then
would they you know where do you see out
all the value of bringing an outside
party to to so see from a third party
because you know as we heard as we heard
in the morning like we are really busy
and dealing with urgent stuff every day
every minute and just sitting back and
looking at it overall becomes really
difficult I yeah and if I it's a good
point my comment at the beginning wasn't
that wasn't like Donald Trump's
acceptance speech I alone can fix this
do you remember that it is that you need
to be a part of that process and you
need to understand it but you should
seek advice from anyone you think will
give you a better answer and for us it
wasn't necessarily an outside consultant
and I'm not averse to that if you think
the person's smart I just wouldn't you'd
have to have a pretty good reference
checking process because this is going
to be a lot of time and energy at a very
critical time for your business
but for us I mean it was we're in a very
supportive community we reached out to a
bunch of different people and said how
did you do this how did you think about
it we talked to our board talked to
investors I mean reached out to a bunch
of different people example I think
about it there's nothing personal about
it right so what is better than people
saying get a coach oh no that's right if
you can get a sales coach that's a good
sales coach do it especially early but
you got to make sure they're good coach
otherwise you're just gonna be in
graining bad habits upfront you need to
be careful about is advice is cheap and
easy right and you have to figure out a
way to get if you're gonna get advice
you have to get someone get their hands
dirty in the business so they understand
some of the nuances of it yes otherwise
you get you see this in boards all the
time it's the it's the cheap
pattern-matching it's the it's the throw
away advice you know I always tell my
students I teach this formation class
and the fall with mark Leslie you know
if you listen to your board all the time
you will guaranteed to get you're
guaranteed to get fired right you just
can't you know the board has so much
advice you just can't follow all of it
and they're not close enough to the
day-to-day to have that nuance of the
business so you should listen to it but
not follow all of it if you're gonna
find a coach or an advisor or a board
member that you really want to get
operational advice from you have to give
them the opportunity and demand from
them that they get their hands dirty in
the business that makes sense yeah - two
questions ones very simple for those of
us who didn't take the course of the GSB
er their books courses recommendations
that you would there's a divorce of the
DFP that covers this material or
something there about C it's a great
question and I wish I did
are there any sales strategies that you
would like to talk about for sort of mid
tier pricing products we sell a product
that is about fifty thousand dollars
average ticket size a little too small
for hunter killers to be out there
hammering the phones all the time with
new business sell too expensive for the
direct internet-based good question I
know you're in that I mean I'd have to
know a lot are ARPU is 6 K so we're our
average customer is 75 K a year but we
have you know two million three million
dollar customers and we have 10,000
customer we've a long tail I'd have to
know a lot more about your specific
situation
software well pricing starts not you you
don't price your product based on what
your go-to-market model is right it's
the other way around you have to figure
out you know pricing is based on the
strength of the value proposition in
competitive landscape you know all these
all these other your call factors and
then you have to figure out what the
right go to market model is and as I
said sometimes there's a disconnect you
know you if you're at 50 K but you
require you know a $300,000 field
salesperson with the systems engineer
and blah blah blah right yeah that
doesn't work then it doesn't work unless
your deal velocity is high enough right
so as an example I had a dilemma again
I'll go back to the VMware example our
average deal size was 10 K but it was an
evangelical sell you imagine you go to a
customer and you say hey we got this
great thing you put it on your on your
server and then an operating system sits
on top of that and then an application
sits on top of that but Microsoft the
operating system vendors don't support
it and the application vendors don't
support us so if something goes running
your count on your own right so is an
evangelical sell for 10k but we were
primarily direct we our average sales
rap OTE was probably two and a quarter
so
how do you make how do you square that
circle well you do a shitload of deals
that's how you work that's how you do it
and so we averaged million to a quarter
productivity per sales rep so the answer
to that so there's all these rules of
thumb like if you're gonna hire a direct
sales organization the deal has to be
greater than 100k and that's generally
the case but not always the case if at
50k I could argue there's a lot of deals
a lot of products or services you could
sell for 50k over the phone so I'm not
convinced that that has to be a field
model nor am I convinced it has to be
100k it's in the Devils in the details
I've seen both ends of the spectrum so
in the back in the last panel that when
hiring you can be industry agnostic so
for example when looking at your sales
team let's say you're a searcher you've
acquired the company you're looking
around for the sales team can I house
higher sales team from any industry or
should it be specifically the industry
that will ask you a question if you're
if you're gonna go sell lasers to the
Department of Defense do you think you
have to have any speculation yeah domain
expertise if you're a start-up in the
storage space for example do you want
your first salesperson to have storage
background I would say absolutely so the
way you have to think about this is is
it's not one size fits all the more
complex the product or the market that
you're selling into or the more arcane
it is the more domain experts expertise
is important one of my previous
companies we sold into healthcare and if
you weren't conversant in Medicare Part
B and and all the regulations that go
and and how the relationships between
you know providers and payers and
customers are you couldn't get past the
first conversation and that's not
something you can train in an afternoon
so but when you get larger and you have
you can build the training and
development infrastructure then you can
start to take people from outside of the
industry now conversely if I'm Dropbox I
don't care who I'm what industry I'm
hiring from because the products so
simple I can train anybody in and after
right so you have to look on that
spectrum between product complexity
market complexity competitive you know
competitive landscape you know from
simple to you know from Dropbox to sa P
my answer to that question is gonna vary
dramatically so I think as a searcher or
as a search fund operator oftentimes you
have to be careful that the industry
that in the hiring process the industry
experience blinds you to deficiencies in
sales ability so I made the mistake of
hiring people I thought were good
because they already knew the words I
was talking about but they weren't good
at sales so I would say it's always
better in this form it's always better
to get good sales people from your
industry but it's a careful balance you
have to look out for yeah that's a great
point it's not either/or
right my questions on the lead
generation you mentioned that funnel
building and lead generation can you
give us an if then you mentioned the
STRs may not be the right kind of hammer
for the nail can you give us an actually
think about the if there's a schism No
well I'm an investor so yes yeah well I
could you know I've been flashed the
card that says we only had a couple
minutes left so I'll keep it really
short and we could catch up later on
this the big challenge I think in some
businesses is that the hardest part of
the sales cycle is what what's hard is
part of the sales cycle horrible
question prospecting you have to think
if you do everything else right closing
the deal is the easiest part of the
sales cycle if you have product market
fit and a strong value proposition and
you go through your stages of the sales
cycle if you do them right you're gonna
get the deal right by and large the
hardest part is the prospecting is
getting people to think about you
differently than the thousand other
people are trying to sell them something
in the same period of time competing for
the same budget differentiy Ferengi
ating themselves and getting your
attention and getting budget that's the
hardest part of the job so who do we put
on
let's take the cheapest least
experienced person let's put them on
that job so make any sense to you
essentially STRs to me in many cases are
a function of sales people not wanting
to prospect and and so not to be too
negative I think if you're in a if
you're in a business that is largely
inbound right no-brainer you need
someone to sort through the chaff and
figure out the real deals and not waste
time on a non-qualified opportunities so
that's kind of a no-brainer
the more transactional the businesses
the more it makes sense to have sdrs
right 5k 10k kind of makes sense right
where you're doing a high volume of
deals because price is a proxy for
complexity so now we're we're on the
lower end of the complexity scale so
putting someone that's young and hungry
and 23 and less experienced doesn't
worry me and they can do more volume
I love the colocation of people together
and the learning dynamic that that
entails and the fast learning cycle for
the business I love all of that as you
move towards more outbound more
complexity qualifying in versus
qualifying out I would argue that more
of the funnel and build needs to fall on
the shoulder of experienced salespeople
the more evangelical the sale is the
more it needs to fall on on the
shoulders of the salespeople if you're
selling something again I go back to the
VMware days if I were an SDR and I
called you up and said listen what's
your budget for virtualization like what
what's that we don't have a budget for
that right the the SDR is and their job
is to qualify in many cases do you have
a budget do you have a project you know
you get all those knows and okay right
so the the sales reps job is to say well
do we have a budget for server
consolidation maybe or have you thought
about the value proposition of
eliminating three data centers and
turning it into one they can talk about
that with your executive team and that's
a sales reps job not an SDR job so you
know there's a lot more there right
right okay
[Music]